les millions de français savoure chaque
jour son esprit bien parisien son sens
de l'humour et son ardeur au travail
suscite l'admiration de tous
saïd et roule à lescun de napoléon de
médias philippe bouvard
[Musique]
et moi finalement en toi tu es un
cynique par goût salé 1 dans une société
d'hypocrites le cynisme fini par être le
compte de la franchise ben oui est ce
que tu as déjà pensé à se suicider le
suicide c'est l'acte désespéré d'un être
qui ne fait plus confiance ni à la
guerre ni aux transports ni aux maladies
nyala nature autre chose et tu favorable
à l'abolition de la peine de mort
l'abolitionnisme c'est une mesure que on
a prises pour qu'un crime ne fasse pas
chaque fois deux mains et tu penses quoi
de l'évolution du métier de journaliste
parce que tu es journaliste tu crois
quoi bouffe il aurait beaucoup à dire
mais bon faute de temps le journaliste
moderne doit choisir où voire
l'événement où le décrire il a rarement
le loisir de faire les deux
je suppose qu'ils avaient un temps tu
voulais faire la révolution
oui ben comme tous ceux qui ont 20 ans
puis après bon bah quand on s'aperçoit
qu'une révolution n'abolit pas les
privilèges mais qu'elles se bornent à
changer les privilégiés et tu penses
quoi de l'amour tarifé bas beaucoup de
bien parce que les prostituées sont des
dames qui ne demande pas qu'on les
invite à dîner avant de passer à l'acte
puis honneur à la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
tout le monde parle de racisme mais pour
toi c'est quoi au juste le racisme basta
la fois un sentiment bas et un sentiment
en pratique puisque ça consiste à en
vouloir à des gens qui sont aisément
repérables et qui généralement sont plus
malheureux que soi si tu devais donner
une définition de la civilisation
je dirais que selon qu'on se met un
anneau
dans le nez ou dans l'oreille on est un
sauvage ou civilisé as tu peur de mourir
enfin ce qui m'embête c'est que la mort
empêche d'aller à ces rendez vous du
lendemain crois tu re l'existence de
dieu
non dieu n'existe pas mais enfin il faut
faire semblant d'y croire parce que ça
lui fait tellement plaisir
vous connaissez le
les admire depuis longtemps philippe
vous avez écrit 30 livres dont vous
dites que ce sont plutôt des articles de
300 pages oui je rêve souvent
et puis là d'un seul coup vous nous
montrez des maximes personnelles que
vous gardiez pour vous secrètement et
que vous publiez sur le titre de penser
au cherche midi
alors si vous aviez une minute pour me
vendre ce que vous diriez quoi je dirais
que j'ai mis quarante ans à l'écrire et
que vous mettrez 40 minutes tel lire
ouais c'est pas mal comme je vous sais
très occupé vous dites que vous n'êtes
plus moraliste que moral ça veut dire
quoi
je te jure que la morale je m'en fous
mais qu' il faut quand même expliquer
aux gens que la vie n'est qu'une énorme
bouffonnerie qu'on vit dans une société
d'obsédé d'hypocrite et qu' il faut se
méfier quoi surtout mais là je fais un
travail de salubrité publique
mais je le fais comme tout le monde
pourrait le faire à mon âge qu au nom de
l'ancienneté de l'expérience puis d'une
petite réflexion point philippe prat
j'étais plus jeune et que je regardais
samedi soir à la télévision
j'avais un rêve c'est d'être un jour
assis à côté de vous sur un canapé et
que vous mmes interviewé des gaves ce
n'est pas chez chapier là je sais que
vous le reprenez d'ailleurs dans votre
bouquin la phrase de are good balle qui
dit que finalement quand un journaliste
interviewe aux journalistes c'est un peu
comme danser avec sa soeur je sais mais
posez moi quand même deux trois
questions
comme vous avez en face de vous
une jeune femme très belle est-ce qu en
lui posant les questions sur son métier
sur sa famille pensait à autre chose
jamais jamais jamais ça m'est jamais
arrivé vous ça vous arrive et vous non
je suis comme vous menteur
et à je voudrais savoir si vous
connaissez vous vous préoccupez de
connaître les réponses aux questions que
vous allez poser
oui en général quand je pose une
question je connais la réponse donc vous
savez quand on vous dit pas la vérité
voilà les ralentis faisait ça je faisais
ça aussi alors quand vous êtes fait
virer d'antenne 2 par jean michel
gaillard et philippe guillôme le même le
même jour que vous à ce moment là vous
avez j'ai rien déclaré je suis le seul à
avoir rien dit vous avez déclaré c'est
une bande de zozos
non j'ai pour éviter de leur faire de la
peine il était viré eux on savait qu'ils
feraient rien d'autre de notre vie
fallait pas de trop méchant vous croyez
que l'audimat monte ou baisse en ce
moment tant donné l'heure il ya déjà pas
mal de gens qui vont se coucher
j'ai même l'impression que les gens qui
nous regardent sont moins habillée qu'au
début de notre conversation vous
travailler 15 heures par jour vous avez
six secrétaires volé six chauffeurs mais
non non combien de chauffeur un
chauffeur faisait qu'un chauffe-eau
aussi bien la peine de ceux de file tout
ce mal mais cinq ce créateur mais avec
quand même vous avez des négos non non
non non non tout vous même en bas oui je
suis méfiant
vous êtes vieux jeu quand même vous
possédez quoi au juste
une balance maison en bonne santé
c'est apparemment un dirty mm à tout
prix il vaut mieux arrêter d'accepter
des invitations comme la vôtre
allongement tirera toujours et vous
dites je mentirais toujours vous parler
des filles du public
vous avez des actions en bourse non mais
des bourses en a qui ont c'est un auteur
d'un style de ce type là non mais j'en
ai eu
puis bon ben j'ai compris que la
spéculation qui n'était pas intellectuel
n'était pas mon fallu renoncer mais
beaucoup plénier toujours de payer trop
d'impôts en fait vous peignez prise en
compte les gens qui viennent comme vous
finalement non je me suis jamais plaint
de payer trop d'impôts je me suis plaint
un que l'on soit pas gentil avec moi
quand je les paye et je paye toujours à
l'heure et au jour dit depuis longtemps
et 2 qu' on envoie mon argent plus mal
que je ne le ferai
ouais vous plaignez quand c'est la
droite au pouvoir penser la gauche au
pouvoir donc finalement votre wii jamais
oui alors que jamais au sérieux je sais
que je ne serai jamais rêvé la nuit avec
la gauche il y avait valeur et que le
centre n'existant plus râleurs rouspète
rouspéter rend ses moyens mais charaf
n'a pas collé un contrôle fiscal pour
vous calmer pas non non non sharon eux
c'est rigolo
vous étiez plutôt chirac jusqu'à ce que
vous rencontriez mitterrand et vous
parliez de jules renard et de flaubert
avec lui et ça vous a fait changer
d'avis l'aifa prof de lettres non non
mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
conversations littéraire l'a fait
passionnante
avec monsieur françois mitterrand mais
c'est indépendant de toute politique on
peut avoir de la sympathie pour un homme
vous avez 62 ans
oui pourquoi continuer ma ba oui
pourquoi
peut-être à cause de celui dont vous
avez cité le nom à cause des carences de
ski à praz ci comprendrait pas que je
m'arrête vous dites toujours je fuis
quelque chose mais au fond c'est plus
que vous fuyez maintenant si je fuis le
chômage en travaillant maintenant que
ses 17 ans mais le poker c'est moins
besoin d'argent quand même ah oui
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins ça va vous
coûter chose truc là ça me coûtait très
chaud je perdais mon argent
mon temps mes nerfs mais nuit et mes
amis qui devenaient des clients alors
c'est vrai que vous étiez fait interdire
en france et vous alliez jouer à
l'étranger séditieuse ça quand même
alors ça vous coûte encore plus cher
parce qu'il ya le voyage dites moi
philippe en mars 81 vous avez poursuivi
un journaliste de paris abdou qui
s'appelait jean michel caradec parce
qu'il avait écouté vos conversations
téléphoniques depuis votre voiture et
vous avez quand même demandé trente
mille francs de dommages et intérêts oui
attendait aviez quelque chose à cacher
non mais non seulement il avait écouté
ce que ce que je disais leur mort a dit
au téléphone mais encore il avait publié
dans un journal qui d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas eu quelques arêtes mais bien
d'autres raisons
j'ai trouvé que bon le comme le je suis
un téléphone aux maniaques qui éclot
radio téléphone et dans nos types de
métiers et nos genres de vie un
instrument primordial il fallait créer
une jurisprudence qui protège les
usagers et ça a été fait c'était une
conversation strictement ces bonnes âmes
c'était pas une aventure même c'était un
groupement privé je parlais d'un tas de
copains bon il y en a que je traitais
bien d'autres que je traitais moins bien
et devoirs huit jours plus tard c'est
imprimé sa touche au dans un journal
ccma agréable pour les copains non plus
le z marié depuis 37 ans oui est ce qui
vous arrive de céder à la tentation
après 37 ans de mariage on va de moins
en moins étant donné mon grand âge
vous avez bien que vous est jamais
arrivé de céder à la tentation orange du
port parce que je tiens à rester dans
les limites d'une certaine vraisemblance
vous avez déjà flashé sur une hôtesse de
l'air qui vous a un sourire commercial
vous avez pris ça pour une avance vos
jeux il ya une bonne histoire comme ça
bon je crois que c'est dans un avion
d'une compagnie israélienne
l'hôtesse demande un passager israélien
son nom qu'elle comprend pas bien son
nom et
lui dit vous mais pelé est aussi est-ce
qu'on peut joueur ce soir 8 humour bon
si vite
vous qui êtes un grand professeur devant
l'éternel vous arrive-t-il de vous
confesser n'ont jamais non enfin là
aussi j'ai pas dit mon dernier mot
nécessité de le dire on y va venez vous
confesser
[Musique]
philippe vous vous présentez souvent
comme titi n'est à montmartre en fête
est née à coulommiers
vous avez honte de votre lieu de
naissance non mais comme je suis partie
de coulommiers alors vu six mois ça n'a
pas tellement influencée en revanche
j'ai passé toute mon enfance et toute
mon adolescence sur la butte montmartre
dont j'ai d'ailleurs comme vous pouvez
le constater gardé l'accent
vous avez une de vos origines sociales
n'en ont pas du tout d'ailleurs
elles sont modestes n'est digne il est
quoi votre papa mon papa était directeur
d'une petite société
ma maman était au petit ciel vous avez
dit je me suis longtemps haye
il s'est passé quoi depuis je me suis
réconcilié avec moi parce que je ne
pouvais pas faire autrement mais c'est
vrai que j'aurais voulu être autrement
physiquement autrement
intellectuellement
d'être plus pure plus dur et que à la
longue on fini par dresser le répertoire
de tous ses défauts et que dans le même
temps les qualités si elles existent
vous apparaissent moins on peut pas
prendre en grippe quelqu'un avec qui on
est condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin et
de surcroît quelqu'un qui vous nourrit
aussi bien les paires de vestiaire j'ai
eu peur de grossir ce que j'ai vu que
mon accommoder bien on je voudrais pas
devenir énorme mais c'est pas mauvais
d'être enveloppé quand on fait un métier
public ça inspire confiance à la
clientèle vous avez fait trente-cinq
mille interview à peu près et celle que
vous avez préféré c'est celle de lanza
del vasto pourvoir 3 parce que c'était
un philosophe qui avait mis en accord
sur harry sim c'est ses pensées et ses
actes c'est à dire qu'il prêchait le
dénuement et vivait
lui-même dans une communauté qu'il avait
monté dans le sud de la france et qui
fonctionnait comme aux premiers temps du
monde
je veux dire sans aucune des ressources
du programme ils filaient lui même le
lin dont il fabriquait ses vêtements
c'est une espèce d'adage d'or et puis
j'ai vu grâce à lui quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais observée jusque là dans
la société française ou contemporaines
l'image d'un désintéressement complet
vous deviez mourir demain vous
regretteriez dame a pas vécu le côté
lanza del vasto de la vie non je pense
qu'il n'était pas fait pour moi j'en ai
deux ports ging
d'autre part bon j'ai eu une bonne
petite existence de deux journalistes
multimédia qui m'a permis d'avoir droit
à une existence à laquelle ne me
destinais
ni mes études limay relation ni mon
physique sur un certain planche quand
même l'impression d'avoir tiré le
maximum du minimum de votre faveur
auprès du temps d'hier est une classe
pour dieu il reste en filigrane de tout
ce que je fais le regret de ne pas avoir
eu la foi et leur grève ou six grands de
ne pas avoir rencontré des gens
susceptibles de me communiquer la leur
vous le regrettez oui et donc maintenant
en semaine on va recevoir quelqu'un que
vous connaissez bien parce qu'il n'a pas
été pour rien dans dans votre carrière
c'est philippe bouvard
les gourmands soir voir alors dans vos
linda hardy heureux les demis france ici
à toute façon on tape bain et on a du
bois on n'a pas la mère de fontenay on a
laissé la vieille à la maison avec son
chapeau pour roman qui met les pieds
dans le plat
pourquoi vous êtes fâché avec un chapeau
non pas du tout on s'adore bon smail
vous connaissez la route façon vous
connaissez tous le monde
alors philippe bouvard vous avez
longtemps sévi vous savez c'est encore
dans la presse la radio la télé
l'édition et vous dites j'ai trouvé mon
équilibre dans le surmenage et quand
vous êtes en vacances en fait le travail
et huit heures par jour seulement 1
c'est ça oui ça l'est les industriels je
suis un petit industriel man à la limite
de l'artisanat le savent bien quand on
étend les fourneaux on n'est jamais sûr
mais rallumer oui c'est vrai alors ces
derniers temps c'est comme un petit peu
moins occupés c'est à dire que vous avez
plus france soir si j'ai recommencé ce
matin jeudi le plus
on peut pas faire de la télé lire les
journaux tous les matins j'ai vu ça
c'est en dernière page france et ça non
oui alors qu'avant c'était en première
page oui mais bon c'est déjà bien
donc vous êtes france soir donc de
nouveau paris match vous n'aurez plus
quand même non non non me continue à
paraître
oui le figaro magazine c'est le berckois
font plus ça continue le figaro magazine
ça continue oui alors sur france 3 c'est
un peu moins de boulot parce que
boulevard du rire ça s'est arrêté pour
l'instant oui ça s'est arrêté
c'est en tout le nouveau directeur de
france 3 voilà voilà
nouveau directeur nouveau président
alors on va voir si les têtes qu'on voit
sur le petit écran sont nouvelles
si ce sont toujours les mêmes alors
restez les grosses têtes donc ces faits
valent trois ans sur sur rtl c'est il ya
plus d'actu il ya moins de sexe est un
peu moins de 2 le sexe souvent
d'actualité oui ah bon vous me rassurez
alors tf1 ça a duré sept ans et
l'émission était arrêté pour vulgarité
oui oui oui non pas vulgarité non non
mais à l'époque pour reprendre la belle
formule d'un de ses dirigeants la chaîne
était en quête de sens oui nous on était
plutôt en quête de sens
ouais et puissante aperçu mais sur le
tard que on disait des choses pas
toujours très convenable à des heures
très ouvrables et donc nous sommes
partis mais faut dire qu'on avait tout
dit à la télé et d'ailleurs vous le
savez tous les deux il n'est jamais très
facile d'adapter quelque chose qui a
marché à la radio au petit écran acl
peux vous le dire
alors j'ai fait un bouquin l'année
dernière qui s'appelait une pâle ordures
et qui est un roman à clés sur tf1 qui a
été quand même censuré
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé en général on
parle beaucoup plus de vos livres ils
n'étaient pas beaucoup plus mauvais que
les zones on en a par le passé ont été
censurés dans paris match par exemple un
papier ces matches à ces coquilles que
je note c'est que vous lui avez dit
l'était pas pris mauvais que les autres
aux couples non mais on en a parlé d'un
truc c'est de la merde entre dans une
émission de télé et puis j'aime beaucoup
la route
oui bon donc j'ai pas été complètement
censuré mais c'est vrai que j'allais un
peu contre l'établissment
audiovisuel que
keane pas l'ordure c'était le surnom
donné un des dirigeants de l'audiovisuel
mois bien sûr je voulais faire le
portrait de personnes jeu comme madame
deviers joncour qui a pris un ministre
comme ça tout à fait par hasard
hazard hasard hein y'a même pas
d'ailleurs un ministre des affaires
étrangères
il y avait pas de ministres étrangers
aux affaires enfin un ministre de la
défense ce qui est normal pour un ancien
avocat donc et donc il ya des gens qui
sont imaginé que je voulais régler des
comptes
oui bon comme si alors que généralement
quand un salarié et quitte une
entreprise les comptes se font dans
l'autre sens mais il était moi j'étais
témoin en tous les cas de la censure
dont ce livre a été été dit il voilà
vous publier un nouveau livre qui
s'appelle joueurs mes frères un de ces
chez robert laffont voilà donc ces 38e
en 38 ans 1
oui il ya deux légendes qui tourne
autour de bouvard 2 int et refuserait
savoir la vérité exacte c'est mireille
mathieu est ce que c'est vrai cette
histoire que vous auriez remis à johnny
stark à l'époque le questionnaire vous
alliez poser comme à mireille mathieu et
qu'au dernier moment vous allez changer
l'ordre des questions et qu'elle a
répondu avec une question de décalage
comme dans toutes les légendes il ya du
vrai et du faux alors il faudrait c'est
que le tonton de génie qu'était un
imprésario comme on n'en fait plus un
c'est à dire ne laissant rien au hasard
m'avait demandé de communiquer mes
questions à l'avant ce qu'on ne fait
jamais de ontologiquement mais compte
tenu
de la jeunesse de mirail de la
sympathique
inspiré à tout le monde moi le premier
j'ai accepté j'ai donné les questions
ensuite qu'est ce qu'il a fait le tonton
johnny il a engagé un dialoguiste et pas
n'importe lequel pour faire les réponses
puis une fois que le dialoguiste a livré
ses réponses il a demandé à la petite
mimi d'apprendre les réponses et la
petite mais il a de la mémoire et les
chansons dans cette société là mais mais
mais faire en plusieurs langues y en a
plusieurs
et puis bah on enregistrait sa à londres
mais en français et j'ai posé la
question numéro roi elle a fait la
question du mais la tension ce numéro un
la question numéro de réponse numéro 2
et à partir de là la machine s'est
complètement détraqué c'est à dire que
j'ai posé la question numéro 3 et
qu'elle a fait la réponse numéro cache
tout a été décalé voilà elle s'était pas
gras de foot mais c'est pas du tout il y
avait aucune vallini deux ans a pas
besoin de magie t il n'y a qu'à les
laisser comme m
mais les américains 2e comme ça ça aussi
il paraît que c'était pour la radio pour
rtl non-stop celle du ca dans un livre
parce que j'ai lu tout ce que tout ce
qui devait arriver c'est pour frédéric
françois
il parie vous lui auriez fait croire qu'
il y avait une tradition en france
c'était comprenait les empreintes comme
à new york à hollywood
comprenez les empreintes des stars place
de la concorde vous y avez mis le pied
dans le plâtre et et s'était filmé la
toute l'équipe fait partie vous l'avez
laissé sri lanka le sien concordent
c'est vrai oui c'était pas place de la
concorde c'était dans un petit coin
retiré sur les bords de la marne et il
était très gentil déjà un et donc on lui
a mis les deux pieds dans le dans le
plainte on a commencé à tourner et puis
il ya quelqu'un de l'équipe technique
qui a dit à mes enfants il est midi faut
il faut aller déjeuner le fruit sa part
eu donc tout à fait normal et tout le
monde s'est levé
sauf lui puisqu'il est le plâtre
commencé à prendre et on a disparu en
lui disant battouta leur vient après le
déjeuner et alors il sentait que le
plâtre gagnait ses chevilles
il aurait bien voulu bouger mais il
pouvait pas il a commencé à appeler au
secours et nous parce qu'on a quand même
un minimum de conscience professionnelle
on l'avait laissé un cadreur pour
continuer à tourner un bon rythme et a
eu deux dentistes qui est une très bonne
idée si les gens étaient assignés à
peut-on identifier s'ils très bonne idée
pour faire des interviews en plus il y
avait
une p'tite [ __ ] je dire je présentais
l'émission seul méga il n'y avait rien
elle monte elle descendait
c'est le très drôle vous êtes trouvent
dans des situations très délicates
je parle évidemment de juin dernier liée
et shelley françois zahoui l'âge était
au centre d'une bagarre homérique
vous saviez que de toute manière il ne
s'appréciaient pas là d'autres je suis
comme tous les provocateurs des ondes
quand je réunis des gens qui ne s'aiment
pas c'est généralement volontairement
hills un jury rond mais pas qu'ils
viendront main ouais la seule qui vous
et gifler paraît-il c'est michel mercier
c'est vrai elle m'a giflé chine parce
que j'avais quand j'avais répété le
propos de son producteur de l'époque
avec lequel elle venait de se fâcher qui
avait dit qu'il avait davantage de
choses dans sa poitrine que dans son
crâne vivant et puis quinze jours plus
tard elle s'était réconcilié avec le
producteur et donc moi elle m'a
rencontrée elle mal mal giflé bon j'ai
vu ces photos par la suite la nature m'a
bien rangée avant avant de passer aux
mika
dans une autre émission évidemment il y
en a plein mais dix ans et le petit
théâtre qui a quand même participé à
lancer ni mathy laspalès chevalier
laurent baffie gaccio qui est l'auteur
principal six chalets points d'affilée
gaccio et auteur principal des guignols
a commencé et smaïn
oui on va avoir un petit bout du feu
monsieur police contrôle identité ou
zéro papier n'ont jamais se crêper bon
choix savary l'accord l'entité la carte
d'identité maintenant était alors la
corée dans tt merci août et algériens
oui ça se voit pas au voie vers une
carte de travail si la blague de travail
carte de séjour la carte de séjour merci
ça va se finir lacq orthez vont faire la
copa seat ivg l'accord n'attendront pas
de la corde attend bouge pas j'ai la
carte de la carte orange tient la corde
à appellation la sécurité sociale la
part des transfusions sanguines va la
connaître
le savoir j'ai peaufiné c'est pas fini
de michalak
j'en attends prix spécial pour toi
monsieur g la frontière
les discours de la méthode d'aidé car on
y va quand même si mon peuple j'ai
encore la carte postale alors vous vous
dites quand vous parlez des jeunes gens
que vous avez lancée à l'époque vous
dites il y en a même qui sont
reconnaissants non je dis pas ça je suis
plus en ce jeudi il y en a quelques-uns
qui ne m'en veulent pas mais à voir et
de les aborder pose une question vous
êtes vous êtes un vrai je pense être un
vrai méchant ou un faux journal non je
n'ai jamais été méchant que pendant les
heures où on me payait pour ça fait
correctement mois faucon surprise parce
que je vous avais jamais rencontré et je
trouve que bon je les ai vus dans les
émissions télé je vous avais un regard
des yeux extrêmement généreux et pas du
tout justement sans se croient tout en
générosité dans mes yeux
alors maintenant je voudrais que serge
khalfon sûr on peut basculer la lumière
parce que maintenant on va passer donc
parce qu on a dit beaucoup de bien de
vous philippe bouvard voix basse et
olive qui s'appelle joueurs mes frères
qui est chez robert laffont
et maintenant on va passer à votre vie
ce parce que il a peut-être des yeux
généreux mais ce type là est un vicieux
linda je voulais que les choses soient
dites dès le départ
alors vous allez donc perdu beaucoup
d'argent aux jeux on va y venir et vous
avez déclaré pan de ce bouquin la seule
façon de tirer profit du jeu quand on
n'est pas casinotier c'est d'écrire un
livre sur le jeu donc j'espère qu'il va
vous rapporter peut-être pas tout ce que
vous avez perdu
non sûrement pas une partie de ce qu'une
partie de ce que vous avez perdu alors
dans le dans le lit vous expliquer qu'en
fait c'est un héritage familial c'est à
dire que devaux arrière-grands-parents à
vos petits enfants chez les bouvard tout
le monde joue tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde ce qui fait que mes
grands parents et mes parents m'ont
légué la passion du jeu mais seulement
ça quand on sait les rênes à jouer avant
ces familles là oui et puis je j'ai moi
même transmis involontairement mais
parce que il ya la fois le jeu de l'inné
et de l'acquis cette passion à mes
descendants qui nous aiment la
transmettrons à d'autres vous vous
jouiez à la belote est de 5 ans quand
même déjà donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même pas mal alors votre première
partie de poker vous avez perdu le mois
de salaire que vous aviez pas encore
touché oui et
la deuxième partie de j'ai fait j'ai
perdu la ned salaires qui devaient
commencer l'exercice suivant
non mais ça ne laisse pas que des bons
souvenirs et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que tout en ne voulant pas brûler ce que
j'ai adoré ce que j'aime encore et tout
en reconnaissant que chaque fois que
j'ai laissé de l'argent dans un casino
j'ai acheté des émotions à nulle autre
pareille
il faut mettre quand même en garde au
moment où il ya une démocratisation de
ce vice car c'est un vice encouragée par
l'état qui trouve son compte
les jeunes et les moins jeunes contre
quelque chose qui est aussi redoutable
sur la drogue et l'alcoolisme
vous allez rencontrer des gros joueurs
vous aviez joué avec yves montand le
baron empain j'ai j'ai vu des gros
joueurs wii par duff parfois comme je
vous vois quelques fois derrière eux en
les regardant jouer
ce sont généralement des spectacles à
yves montand vous dites là dans vsd je
vois que c'était un joueur méchant yves
montand il ya des joueurs méchant ça
veut dire quoi les gens méchants fâché
non pas du tout ce sont des dd alors bon
c'était pas que le cas de deux montants
qu'ils avaient une brillante carrière il
ya des gens qui vous font payer une
table de poker
les déboires qu'ils ont eue dans leur
vie professionnelle ou y arriver ça cet
affreux et puis d'autres d'autres qui
ont un complexe de supériorité et qui
les pousse après avoir pris leur argent
à quelqu'un qui joue moins bien que à
lui dire tout le mal qu'il pense de sa
façon de jouer en poème patrick bruel il
est comment c'est un très bon joueur un
bon joueur et un bon joueur il est
champion à las vegas
d'ailleurs quoi quand j'ai lu le bouquin
ça m'a rappelé un des années 70 j'ai eu
beaucoup d'amis qui étaient accrochées à
l'héroïne qui étaient de jeunes qui je
peux vous dire que quand on lit beaucoup
c'est vraiment une drogue dure quoi vous
dites on joue pas pour gagner mais pour
acheter des émotions fortes et le flèche
d'adrénaline qu'on n'a rien fait
exactement comme un sou attendait et
l'émotion la plus forte faut quand même
se le savoir sinon on comprend rien à la
psychologie du joueur c'est dans la
perte qu'on l'obtient dur vous gagnez
bon vous êtes sur un petit nuage vous
avez plus intelligente tout le monde
les autres joueurs les casinotiers
croupier mais c'est rien ça alors que
quand vous tombez au fond c'est
suicidaire s'est suicidé rennais femme
et ses complices s'en sert bien sûr
c'est complètement suicidaire
comment des femmes n'est pas rendu des
gens malheureux autour de vous non mais
pour ne pas les rendre malheureux j'ai
travaillé beaucoup plus que j'avais
envie de travailler et qu'il n'était
raisonnable de travailler parce que
quand on a à la fois un vie c'est une
famille à nourrir faut travailler bout
non c'est vrai que votre niveau de vie
vous évite enfin le maire dans le
bouquin le misérabilisme
moi j'avais interviewé guy lux qui a
perdu beaucoup d'argent au jeu et qui
m'avait raconté cette anecdote et vous
il n'ya pas d'anecdotes aussi aussi dur
dans votre villa il me disait quand
j'étais jeune mariée la veille de noël
j'ai tout perdu aux cartes et il me
restait même pas de quoi faire un cadeau
à ma femme à mes enfants
c'est terrible ça quand même si vous
souhaitez que j'ai une histoire quand
même à la suite de laquelle je me suis
arrêté de jouer pendant dix ans un jour
jeudi à georges cravenne que d'un
publiciste tout à fait connu estimable
et qui organisait une partie régulière
je le prend à part j écoute georges
cette partie elle commence à m'inquiéter
lucien morisse
s'est donné la mort après une succession
de participants et directeur artistique
d'europe numéro à la grande époque
anatole litvak est mort le soir d'une
partie sami ciridd ce qui est mort après
une partie
bertrand jamal qui est peut-être un
producteur a essayé deux fois de se
suicider il a fait faillite et hindi je
sais bien mon vieux mais qu'est ce que
tu veux qu'on fasse d'autres le samedi
sur le marché rim ferait dans sa case
nous maintenons hilali matters alors il
est passé du bon côté du tapis vert
et il est du côté des casinotiers oui
mais c'est un très grand joueur oui ça
va c'est un grand joueur et un éminent
théoricien du black jack
c'est un vieux jetons maintenant alors
il ya part et au delà du jeu un petit
bout on vient faire le bilan de vos
années de jeu et de vos activités dans
le jeu vous avez dit comment peut-on
avoir écrit au temps sans avoir écrit
une oeuvre quelle performance et c'est
dans un bouquin qui est là qui vous dit
c'est mon premier livre vous qu'on vous
en parle et ça arrive assez étonnant
s'appelle journal de philippe bouvard
c'est au cherche midi éditeur et là
alors vous êtes d'une dune franchissent
voire d'une crudité avec vous même assez
incroyable j'ai fini par me le pardonner
mais quand je me suis relu la première
fois vraiment jeté sous terre ils enfin
free 1
par exemple vous dit voyez j'ai relevé
trois phrases mais qui sont vraiment
fous faut avoir le courage d'écrire ça
sur soi même vous êtes un jour je
décrirais par le menu la longue série
d'échecs que peut dissimuler une
apparente réussite pour tout le monde
peut le monde pour ldc mais vous dites
un peu plus loin je suis devenu un de
ces personnages qui me dégoûte est le
plus quand j'avais 20 ans un vieux plein
de fric et de certitudes
il reste les certitudes le fric 120
casino pour perdre ans de normes si vous
n'êtes pas commander phishing fort
complémentaires si vous n'écrivez pas ça
pour qu'on vous dise qu'on vous alignant
j'écris ça parce que l'autodérision est
la seule façon de désamorcer la dérision
c'est bien vous êtes assez de quel signe
alors aimer dit oui pouvoir ils croient
pas et astrologie quand même non pas du
tout pas non non non non
à chaque fois qu'on me faire un débat
sur l'astrologie
philippe contre les aberrations maintien
contre les dernières phrases toujours
tirer de ce livre qui est assez étonnant
journal de boulevard
si j'étais un autre je ne me ferais
compterait pas oui c'est vrai
pas parce que on revient sur les
relations je suis un autre j'aurais
envie de vous fréquentez skin lentilles
disconvient serviable un bien sûr de
finir pdac suis là j'ai commencé comme
salon et et géronte en chine merci
philippe bouvard on aurait aimé la
lumière je reste
on passe au dessus quiz
alors le boxing prise c'est un enjeu non
pose des questions et la réponse c'est
le nom de quelqu'un voilà c'est je suis
il faut deviner qui sait vous allez
trouver très facilement
on va tout donner un exemple qu'on a
déjà évoqué tout à l'heure par exemple
je porte le nom d'un mime et c'est vrai
parfois que je ferais mieux de la fermer
marceau c'est là c'est évident le public
peut jouer aussi si on trouvait bien
entendu alors les gagnants gagneront le
comme d'habitude le livre de l'anc et
voilà un homme qui pour eux est
quelqu'un que philippe bouvard connaît
bien justement j'ai fait un huitième
enfant à ma jeune épouse de porc que ce
soit michel drucker qui meurent en
classe pour faire une neuvième chaque
matin c'est vous êtes martin c'est la
dame la bac a gagné qu'on salue au
passage pendant que je suis en prison
pendant que je suis en prison j'espère
que ma femme ne s'en tricote pas un
autre nom connaît bonnet bravo semaine
deux semaines qu'il ait envie pour toi
j'en ai une poubelle on l'attendait je
suis tout petit tout rouge et je frappe
à une vitre buchhart dans un four
micro-ondes petit j'ai prévu la fin du
monde pour le 11 août c'est parce
qu'avec le gêne pas le temps de terminer
c'est parce qu'avec le pont du 15 août
sont là quand même de faire un week-end
prolongé
c'est quand même pas mal ah tiens un peu
plus compliqué lors des derniers
championnats d'europe je n'ai pas obtenu
de médaille d'or
parce que les seules pièces jaunes que
je récupère maintenance avec bernadette
chirac doulieu douillet bravo bouvard
vous l'avez déjà
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui n'a l'actualité en ce
moment aussi et la cgc et de prouver que
je suis une personne sensible parce que
si j'avais été sensible j'aurais pas
tirer à l'arc goes my rosemary brown
[Applaudissements]
dernière allez une dernière
je suis toujours habillée en noir parce
que ça me minci et g3 coussin sous les
fesses parce que ça me fait tout drôle
au niveau que mardi son regard derrière
les regards d'égoûts varois de viol mais
regardez maintenant parce que vous
l'avez là je me sens vraiment à ce que
vous ne savez pas c'est que moi je suis
debout
allez on allait lui rendre merci non
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça va bien mais avec votre
tabouret j'ai mes petites jambes qui bat
dans le but d'aller vous avez quand même
les pieds qui touche le ça va bien alors
donc c'est vrai que michèle bernier et
elle est auditionnée au petit théâtre de
bouvard en 83 et elle a dit d'ailleurs à
la suite de son expérience avec vous
elle a dit deux ans et demi d'éclats de
rire
la liste est formidable parce que grâce
au petit théâtre de bouvard on avait un
nom connu un visage reconnu et on a été
plus on avait plus de comptes dans le
rouge
quand vous avez été très important pour
elle c'est pour ça que suis content que
vous retrouviez ce soir oui je suis un
des hommes de sa vie et ça me réjouit
mais on avait calculé une fois avec les
copains que parce qu'on faisait
l'émission de télé on partait une fois
par semaine en province on jouait le
soir au théâtre et on avait calculé
qu'on faisait à peu près 18 heures
devant martine aubry ont été inspirés
que vous avez passé de bons moments avec
michel mais en ce moment c'est pas là
c'est un peu chez rtl oui c'est la
première fois que les grosses têtes me
rend triste là que je les pratiques
depuis 24 ans avec un certain bonheur et
puis là bas c'est l'histoire des saveurs
d'un amour qui se termine mais là on ça
mais bien tous les deux il a fallu qu'il
arrive une troisième personne alors
j'explique à nos amis téléspectateurs
qui ont peut-être pas tous lu la presse
cette semaine
donc les grosses têtes qui a été
qualifié démission du siècle après un
sondage du parisien qui faisait quatre
points l'après-midi ce qui est et ce qui
était énorme deux millions sept
d'auditeurs sur rtl tous les jours
depuis 24 ans alors vous quand vous avez
créé l'émission au bout d'un mois vous
vouliez l'arrêter parce que ça va lâcher
c'était pas du tout le délire que c'est
devenu aujourd'hui c'était d'abord
uniquement culturel ensuite il y avait
pas de public doit qui avait pas de
fronton pour renvoyer la balle et en
matière de comics ça rend très difficile
ce jeu alors aujourd'hui bon vous êtes
viré on peut le dire c'est pas l'amour
est un peu triviale mais bon ça nous est
arrivé à tous après faire lourder pas ce
que l'on sait c'est pas fait légèrement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous dites en parlant du nouveau
patron des programmes de rtl qui a
remplacé philippe labro qui est
peut-être parti d'ailleurs pour pas
avoir à faire ça et d'avoir du sang sur
les mains ou dit en parlant de lui
stéphane duhamel et son entourage se
sont comportés comme des gougnafiers
quelle est votre définition du goon
yafié je crois que c'est un homme sans
coeur et sans éducation
ouais moi aussi tout ça suffit bah oui
il est comme ça ben pour l'hiver alors
la raison de votre votre éviction des
grosses têtes c'est le rajeunissement à
cause de la fameuse ménagère lannoy 50
l'aménager alpha 2
méfiez vous en êtes vous rattrapera j'en
suis sûr eh bien oui et alors là il ya
un discours quand même qui est
extrêmement risqué de la part de la
direction de la station
il a revient à dire à des auditeurs qui
sont fidèles depuis des années et qui
sont des gens merveilleux attachés à
leur station
comme on est attaché à sa famille vous
êtes trop vieux cassez vous 1
ouais c'est ça être a dit de très
délicat admettez qui prennent ce
discours à la lettre un et qui se
suicident tous imaginé que des suicides
collectifs d'auditeurs d'air théâtre la
valise on avalise m'attend mais c'est
que fabrice aussi un oui oui mais bon
c'est la valise pour tout le monde
dites moi alors c'est vrai que ces deux
là même qui l'avait remplacé à ça je ne
sais pas c'est un problème de direction
et je suis pas directeur parce que si
j'étais directeur je me serais garde
alors donc on annonce sur la tl
l'arrivée de laurent gerra ouais c'est
bien ça voilà de marc olivier fogiel qui
vient de chez moins bien que canal+
pourquoi vous dites que c'est moins bien
proche que je laime porcs allait
d'accord c'est un bobard déjà il n'avait
pas sa langue dans sa jeunesse le signe
du sagittaire maintenant c'est la
balance
[Musique]
alors alors vous dites quand même
philippe bouvard rendez-vous au prochain
sondage parce que c'est vrai que l'après
midi risque même d'avoir un trou là
parce que vous étiez très très loin non
plus mon problème - alors que jusqu'à
présent tous les trois mois je guettais
les sondages avec des douleurs excellent
oui oui oui il y avait une petite baisse
il ya trois ans pour se rattraper en
allant plus vers l'actualité et on peut
même pas vous reprochez pas vous
renouveler parce que vous aviez décidé
d'aller plus vers l'actualité de faire
des choses plus en liaison avec l'info
quoi oui c'était d'ailleurs pas la
solution de facilité parce que là on
travaille comme disent les industriels
en flux tendu flux tendu m'en parlez pas
et à partir d'un certain âge c'est pas
facile et et que avant comme c'était
totalement intemporel j'avais six
semaines de réserve je pouvais partir en
vacances vous voyez aussi beaucoup de
pub ça leur apporter du pognon votre
émission parce que les membres je veux
dire que les grosses têtes constitue une
excellente plateforme publicitaire
puisque on est à saturation
sur ce plan là enfin c'est déjà du passé
et terry parce que quand on prend des
taxis l'après midi qu'est-ce qu'on va
écouter maintenant dans les taxis
l'après-midi moi il m'est pas interdit
ça derrière d'aller ailleurs
oui c'est même un encouragement à 10
heures alors on pourrait dire que c'est
votre physique vous dit de toute façon
le physique en radio il s'assure de rien
ah ouais rien du lavoir juste bonne à la
voix est excellente
j'ai la voix de philippe bouvard alors
vous dites vous aviez déclaré quand même
il ya quelques années un jour mon refus
de vieillir sera pathétique c'est à dire
qu'est ce que voilà est-ce que
finalement au-delà de odette c'est je
crois vous avez bien fait de m'inviter
cette semaine c'est encore passable mai
prochain on va passer une question
importante
une question difficile de madame belber
deloche dont vous avez fait une question
importante
vous avez une carrière multimédia
incroyable on pas tout citer parce que
sinon on sera encore là deux heures du
matin enfin il légende bouvard
l'autodidacte jamais à l'abri d'être
autocritique moraliste boulimique
boulimique de travail boulimique
d'argent vivent bien la limousine bureau
les ferrari la piscine problèmes
d'argent pour les mecs le fisc problème
est qu'elle casino où vous avez été
obligé de vous faire interdire de casino
à la sortie tellement ça vous coûter
cher
et puis on sentait toujours chez vous
une espèce de une espèce de fêlures
[Musique]
mais est ce que tout ça finalement non
mais cette espèce de on sentait toujours
chez vous malgré votre succès vous dit
tout le temps oui je travaille beaucoup
c'est une fuite en avant
je me suis longtemps à hisser votre côté
françois nourissier d'ailleurs j'ai
toujours voulu être connue pour autre
chose que qu'un animateur est ce que
finalement maintenant et c'est le but de
ma question est ce que maintenant vous
allez pas avoir le temps de faire ce que
vous avez pas fait jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai raté un peu ma vie j'aurai m
petites soeurs des pauvres grand frère
dérivés c'est bien c'est bien aussi un
petit vous auriez pu excuse n'est pas
avoir le temps d'écrire maintenant si
bien sûr mais je l'avais aussi j'ai
quand même public et 40 lits m'arrête 40
libre ouais d'ailleurs si on va parler
du dernier
vous faites pas vous de 1 oui
vous non
donc
je vais pas vous interviewez vous allez
faire vous avez vous êtes un très bon
interviewer êtes un de mes maîtres ben j
ai mon maître quand j'étais petit il ya
très très longtemps un vous vous auto
interviewé
[Applaudissements]
non
ces renforts
posez vous des questions et répondez à
la première question que je me pose
c'est pourquoi dire du mal de moi oui
bon ben parce que je suis sûr que je me
ferais jamais de procès et a envie de me
demander qui auriez-vous aimé être et là
je répond sans hésiter un grand brun
avec un polo noir question alors plus
angoissante quel est le désagrément
d'être philippe bouvard et bien je suis
condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin avec
quelqu un qu autrement j'aurais sûrement
pas fréquenté j'aurais aussi envie de me
demander ce que je reproche aux femmes
eh bien je reproche aux femmes ce que
drieu la rochelle reprocher aux femmes
qu'ils avaient aimé c'est à dire d'être
assez peu exigentes pour se contenter de
moi
la question qui généralement vient à la
fin d'une interview vous bien menée et
la vôtre était fabuleuse c'est le père
de vous et bien c'est une idée mieux que
j'ai fait et si c'était à refaire
oui et bien j'irai chez lagaf le
dialogue est plus facile
et
il
d'abord c'est incroyable philippe alors
vous citez souvent cette phrase de
heartbeat cheval qui dit quand un
journaliste interview un autre
journaliste comme quand on danse avec sa
soeur j'aimerais avoir une soeur alors
vous dites également et ça c'est pas de
boer valls êtes vous un jour mon refus
de vieillir sera pathétique
oui c'est pas encore aujourd'hui le plus
gros est fait dans ce sens
oui mais ça va encore peser très bonne
mine je voulais vous féliciter oui vous
avez d'excellentes maquilleuse a alors
vous refusez de raccrocher les gants et
fut une nouvelle fois bien de
reconnaître retour sur rtl pour
reprendre les grosses têtes
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles de
stéphane duhamel c'est lui qui vous a
mis 2 non non non je les croisais mais
dans deux événements parisiens là il ya
eu un petit ballet bien réglé ou celles
à la chorégraphie des gens qu'ils
s'aperçoivent mais qu'ils veulent pas se
dire bonjour
chacun est parti d'un cô te moques si on
veut pas du mal que j'ai pu dire sur lui
après avoir été lourde et vous avez là
nous dire de spécial c'est là maintenant
c'est réglé armes se régler tous les
gens qui m'avaient poussé dehors sont
allés ailleurs mais je n'en demandais
pas tant
alors après notre retour sur rtl
philippe vous avez publié un livre qui
s'appelait la belle vie après 70 ans ou
vous révéliez qu'un quart des français
de 70 ans font l'amour trois fois par
semaine alors que la moitié des 60 ans
le font deux fois par mois
oui c'est une statistique on m'a
communiqué je n'ai pas mise en doute
je ne vais pas non plus vérifié à l'aune
de mon propre comportement rhin en fait
ça marche comment écouter
je pense que
je vis comme si j'avais 30 ans comme
quand j'avais 30 ans mais
de façon parfois un peu plus modéré le
plus prudente et en travaillant
davantage parce que chemin faisant j'ai
laissé tomber quelques vis donc vous
repartez au combat philippe bouvard ce
qui est absolument extraordinaire à
l'âge de 73 ans vous devenez directeur
général de france soir en charge du
contenu du marketing de la pub
non mais vous savez je suis un
collaborateur non pas historique de ce
journal mais préhistorique
il ya 30 ans aujourd'hui que
j'y faisais mon entrée je suis très
attaché à ce titre très attaché au
quotidien qui ne laisse à ceux qui
travaillent à ce rythme pratiquement
aucun répit on sort jamais de
l'actualité je me suis dit il ya un
problème pour la presse quotidienne
nationale et d'ailleurs il commence à
atteindre la presse quotidienne
régionale
c'est que l'offre qu'on fait aux
consommateurs d'information ne
correspond plus à leur demande et si
cette offre ne correspond plus à la
demande c'est parce que la presse
quotidienne nationale n'a guère changé
depuis 1945 alors que le panorama
médiatique c est complètement
bouleversée il ya peu de raison en tout
cas beaucoup moins que par le passé que
quelqu'un qui a eu la veille au soir
gratuitement à domicile des informations
un sorte de chez lui le lendemain matin
pour aller les acheter
bon donc il faut faire autre chose et je
suis partie de ce postulat que qui
demandent qu'à être vérifiée mais dans
ce cas là ce sont les lecteurs comme les
téléspectateurs qui ont toujours le
dernier mot que
la télévision nous avait fait beaucoup
de mal et est en train de nous tuer
et que peut-être si on prenait en compte
le fait télévisuelle elle nous
ressusciterons alors ça signifie que je
vais avoir dans le journal tous les
jours 10 pages consacré à la télévision
et pas dix pages à froid avec des avants
papier uniquement des programmes non non
avec du show avec les critiques de la
veille même de la veille au soir
et puis on n'avait pas le choix c'était
la performance ou mourir
moi je préfère la performance alors
c'est très bien mais c'est quand même la
deuxième fois que vous êtes chargé de
sauver france soir la première fois que
vous l'avez sauver c'est entre 87 et 89
tiré à 450 midi en plein rallye
oui oui et à jouer ça continue à
descendre quand même là vous êtes à 70
mille ha oui oui oui oui et je voudrais
que d'ici les vacances nous nous ayons
repris un niveau plus normal d'ailleurs
on retrouvera pas le million le million
de la seine à melun
mais à ce moment là les les médias
n'étaient pas ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
en revanche en revanche 120 milles l'un
semble aujourd'hui une hypothèse
plausible
bon vous serez pas obligé de sauver
trois fois c'est ça que je veux dire non
en bas on attendait la dernière chance
je me prends ça parce que c'est vraiment
très très triste de penser que si ça ne
marche pas exactement comme on veut y
aura plus de france soir pourquoi dans
les taxis chaque fois qu'on rentre il ya
les grosses têtes
eh bien ce sont entrés que c'est un
grand prime comme 10
les publicitaires et les hommes
politiques je crois que les taxis sont
des relais d'opinion 1 et les chauffeurs
de taxi qui sont sensibles à cette bonne
humeur générale
il ya cet irrespect total parce qu'on ne
respecte rien ni personne et on a très
souvent pris françois bayroux comme tête
de turc s'était avancé vers l'avant non
non on continue on a espoir était latent
et tout va bien mais françois pien ou là
ça y est le tenant d'un islam a parlé
alors qu'il a dû leur vendre depuis
longtemps de son autobus colza vous avez
compris ce truc
ouais françois c'est une des meilleures
idées que j'ai jamais eu
c'est dire la qualité des autres
c'était vraiment le truc le plus sympa
qu'on pouvait imaginer d'aller
rencontrer les gens en bus ça marche ça
a marché très bien en allemagne
ça marchait très bien grande bretagne ça
marchait très bien aux états unis qu'en
france
et donc les chauffeurs de taxi nous
aiment ils nous écoutent tout le temps
et quand on vous montez dans un
chauffeur de taxi
outre l'émission
forcément dix mois non mais sérieux
alors maintenant sérieusement pourquoi
pourquoi pas profiter de votre votre
maison sur les hauteurs de cannes dont
ferrari votre piscine et tout ça faut
quand même que ce soit terrible chez
vous pour vous passer autant de temps à
bosser à votre âge là qu'est ce qu'elle
dit colette si c'est pas très sympa pour
elle cette espèce de d'âpreté wing l'eau
comme ça j'aurai une maison sur les
hauteurs de calme jusqu'au boulot aussi
tout le temps or mon côté je vais vous
dire je ne travaille pas je m'amuse
ouais j'ai la veine comme vous que
d'exercer en même temps un métier
bifteck un métier passion et je me suis
habitué à ne rien faire d'autre que de
travailler si je m'arrête de travailler
je suis un homme mort et ça ferait
plaisir à trop de monde
[Applaudissements]
je remarque qu'en maine philibeaux
barque depuis que vous êtes ici vous
n'avez fait aucune citation
et pourtant vous êtes le roi de la
situation 1 vous avez ça en commun avec
philippe sollers et et jean d'ormesson
on va faire une interview qui a dix qui
a vu le plus beau moment de l'amour
c'est quand on monte l'escalier coluche
non non et tristan bernard
tristan bernard
[Applaudissements]
je vérifiais quand j'étais jeune ma
tranche pas le faire quand y en a
forcément qui a dit quand j'écoute trop
wagner j'ai envie d'envahir la pologne
woody allen qui est dit on ne prête
qu'aux riches on a raison les pauvres en
bourse difficilement comment ça pourrait
ça pourrait être alphonse allais nom
jules renard
non tristan bernard eh oui qui est dit
au paradis on était assis à la droite de
dieu c'est normal c'est la place du mort
c'est la place du marché
qui est dit tyr liban pont sur les
chihuahuas à carlos suite
l'éducation nationale après son arrêt
exactement qui a dit je suis un
agitateur ans provocateur un vrai animal
manalich je suis à l'agitateur un
provocateur mais ces réseaux se
présentait déjà j'adore sur des oeufs
immédiat c'est logique non séance la
moins dense comment alors vous savez
glisser les enfants c'est qu'il s'est
dit voilà la culture moderne ça je dois
dire jean pascal de l'astarac paru non
mais il ya certains grands auteurs à
côté desquels je suppose mais là on voit
bien là on voit bien de posséder
les rations crise tombe bien on a
et jean pascal de la star à séverac
tristan bernard bon il n'a pas été lents
loft qui est dit paris paris on t'encule
ils sont plusieurs lorraine ce nombre
pourrait passer le reste des français on
à wimereux les supporteurs de noël
qui a dit quel connard c'est philippe
bouvard c'est un ami à vous non
m
soir
passe pas
tirage 150000 un tirage de 500 mille
exemples oh là là et vous allez voir
avec plein de nouvelles rubriques avec
de la publicité comme s'il en pleuvait
enfin un c'est la résurrection
on vous le souhaite bonne chance et
maintenant
[Musique]
voici vie libre
et bien comme des gens simples
franchement là il ya quand même plus
petit que vous ne mesurez combien
philippe sérieusement écoutez un peu
moins d'un mètre 70 mais bon les
escabeaux sont pas faits pour les chiens
en tous les cas je suis content de vous
recevoir
j'ai passé tellement de samedi soir à
vous regarder mais je savais je savais
que j'étais regarder parce qu'ils
prendraient ma place un peu plus tard
bien alors philippe bouvard journaliste
écrivain polémiste homme de télévision
et de radio vous fait les grosses têtes
depuis 1977 et vous avez resigné pour
trois ans ce qui va vous mener en 2007
ce qui va faire 30 ans de grosses têtes
c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on se demande plus vite bouvard si
vous n'êtes pas immortel parce que là
vous êtes là de toute éternité que je
disparaîtrai pour vous alors mais
sérieusement si un jour vous deviez
disparaître ce que je ne veux pas croire
mais vous voudriez que ça se passe
comment voudrait mourir comment philippe
dans vos bras
ah oui votre dernier bon mot ça serait
quoi
or ça mais il faut se méfier des
derniers bons mots parce que souvent ils
n'ont pas été prononcés ils sont
totalement inventés mais j'ai déjà prévu
mon épitaphe eux il y est passée comme
les autres le titre de libération lanata
voudrais que ça soit quoi on chaux de
fonds une étoile c'est à la cérémonie
vous rich
je pense que bon il ya pour ma naissance
il y avait pas grand monde pour la fin
je crois que enfin il faut pas qu'ils
aient plus d'influencé vous voiler la
même équipe il ya des gens qui sont pas
10 pour l'est peut-être laurent pour
dire quelques mots et carlos pour faire
une blague ou éventuellement ici
philippe bouvard pourrait-on cortège des
mots d'auteur cortège de chauffeurs de
taxi aussi non ah bah ça je leur dois
beaucoup vous imaginez quand même le
corbillard suivi par 12 mille taxi et se
sert en l'air du taurion formidable la
cérémonie briquet soit votre transmises
sur rtl sur tf1 non je vous dis la plus
grande discrétion mais coupure pub quand
même oui parce qu'il faut qu'on prenne
mais il ya toujours des frais et gardien
de billard les roses ça vous plairait
qu'on rebaptise bobino le grand théâtre
de bouvard
non non non non non non même un truc
comme ça c'est j'en ai beaucoup croquer
j'ai plus fin ouais ah oui voilà c'est
dommage parce qu'on avait pris sa
formidable
donc sur votre pierre tombale on may cry
j'en ai beaucoup coquet plus fin
[Musique]
et la commande à la belle paire de c
avec un moment on vous cela d'abord sait
même pas si elle a jamais existé est
et puis vraiment j'en ai marre qu'on me
parle tout le temps de son album fame
que j'aie jamais rencontré le pria
d'agon coutainville
elle est morte bonne réponse de fait les
beaux
alors
alice nayo philippe qui s'appelle des
femmes et je vais le résumé m
ça
et la magie
voilà le résumé du livre de philippe
bouvard puisqu'il s'agit de 77 portraits
de femmes le sexe fort dites-vous le
véritable c'est que ce fort est oui mais
moi à toi tu serais pas un peu féminine
j'ai voulu non pas faire des 77
portraits de femmes célèbres mortes 77
archétype de femmes voilà voilà
oui tout arrive caractère caractère un
peu comme la bruyère on pourrait dire
alors il ya j'en ai pris quelques unes
comme ça il y alors à la don juan
philippe dit personne ne saurait refuser
ses avances sans être suspecté
d'homosexualité ou d'impuissance
ah ben oui là faut il penser mais il est
comme ça ah ben heureusement les
claudine assélé sexuels alors que linda
recéler sexuelle vous l'appelez la main
courante
oui parce que chaque fois qu'on l'a
effleuré sans vous d'ailleurs malice
dans la rue ou dans un transport en
commun elle va porter plainte au
commissariat alors c'est le surnom
collet les policiers lui en donnent la
main courante
aya grâce les sérieuses de régime elle
est comme ses vêtements elle craque de
temps en temps c'est vrai que c'est tout
ça est plein de plasne formule dont vous
avez le secret oui moi je pense que ce
sont des portraits trains courts donc il
faut qu'ils aient des formules c'est pas
un roman j'ai pas écrit la vie de 77 fin
sinon
enfin je serai pas fini alors j'ai voulu
que chacune soit cerné par quelques
traits qui corresponde à la réalité
je voudrais que le lecteur ait des
lectrices éventuellement parce que c'est
pas fait pour un seul sexe recherche
dans cette typologie des personnages qui
correspondent à des gens de son
entourage tout le monde se retrouve
évidemment il ya marie la servante
maîtresse et vous avez cette phase
formelle porter la culotte parce qu'elle
avait su l'enlever abbas à guitry écoute
c'est gentil ça pour un compliment et
son mec là couché sur son testament
voyager intrus de la momie ça c'est
moins sympa squelette ambulant échappé
du crématorium des uv plus rien la
froisse tellement elle est déjà fripé
j'adore quand irib ouvert un ben oui ça
a des limites
comment tu fais ta naissant qui bouge
comme des vecteurs les philippot célia
ludivine l'animatrice va c'est pas un
archétype ça c'est clairement le
portrait de quelqu'un qu'on connaît
robert ya plusieurs personnalités pas
quel bouquet quand elle rose c'est sûr
qu'ils ne pourront pas faire mentir les
journalistes qui ont annoncé sa
séparation ou mais ça c'est valable pour
beaucoup de gens qui me l'a reconnu là
n'ont accordé la fille qui vous en
connaissez c'est pas tout à fait celle
que vous connaissez entre claire chazal
et madame ferrari quoi ouais avec
un zeste qu'elle verra rien d'autre avec
cela dit ce serait déjà beau nom mais
assez parlé de chabwa c'est ce que je
veux dire
alors ça c'est alors la lasser des
souvenirs personnels
c'est olga la masseuse perverse qui est
pleine de diplômés d'attention
thérapeutique mais enfin qui va jusqu'au
bout avec les mecs quoi c'est un
souvenir personnel ça non non mais vous
savez j'ai recueilli beaucoup de
confidences dans ma vie et le temps en
temps j'ai été moi-même au charbon parce
qu'on peut pas croire tout ce que les
gens disent que sympa ton rôle ya et il
y en a une qui est l'archétype de toutes
les femmes pour moi c'est odile la
madone du train bleu qui se tape un mec
dans le train bleu pendant que son son
jules l'attend sur le quai et derrière
ça j'ai connu un peu connu un oui c'est
le mystère des femmes ça c'est un truc
que je n'arriverai jamais à comprendre
chose avec nous mais pas du tout
justement tu va célébrer comme c'est un
homme qu'on n'est pas tout seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors philippe en dise et que c'est des
petits portraits la façon de la bruyère
des petites maximes qui deviendront
peut-être des citations
alors je vous faire une interview faire
valoir
[Musique]
alors comme je suis gentil respectueux
avec vous on va parler de vos citations
et je vous ai préparé des fiches avec
vos citations comme ça vous n'aurez même
pas besoin de vous en servir et vous
aller briller intense émotion quand vous
astique jeune fille vit vous avez des
questions à des questions c'est moi qui
les posent et les réponses c'est vous
qui les fait voilà c'est pas gentil ça
pour vous c'est quoi un artiste ben
c'est quelqu'un qui a réussi à
transformer des défauts caractériel en
qualité professionnelle même carlos
etes-vous modeste oui mais vous le savez
la modestie cesse à l'instant où on
commence à en parler
pourquoi avez vous essayé de tricher
avec les impôts philippe jeu
les impôts ont été inventés pour tout le
monde n'est pas envie de réussir
vous n'êtes pas un peu nouvelle fois là
on appelle mauvaise foi les convictions
d'autrui qu'on ne partage pas vous
pensez quoi des hommes bah je m'étonne
toujours que des êtres également menacé
par la mort se fasse la vie aussi
difficile alors qu'il doit y avoir une
solidarité de condamner êtes vous un
honnête homme philippe bouvard
l'honnêteté la seule méthode qui
permette d'escroquer plusieurs fois la
même personne
comment expliquez vous qu'on voit plus à
la télé c'est votre image non vous savez
nous vivons dans un monde où l'échec des
autres devient plus importante notre
propre réussite
vous avez du talent selon vous non non
mais bon le talent consiste à dire les
mêmes bêtises que les autres mais plus
élégamment et j'ajouterais parce que
c'est un des principes fondamentaux de
la radio plus vite que les autres
avez vous peur de vieillir a fait le
pouvoir non je suis curieux de voir ce
que ça donne quoi que bon le matin je
suis prêt à tout le jeu
réjoui de ce que je jouais dans le
miroir de ma salle de bains mais je
pense que les hommes sont comme les vins
lorsqu'ils deviennent meilleurs en
vieillissant c'est qu'ils sont d'une
certaine qualité vous avez du caractère
non pas dans notre société on dit que
quelqu'un du caractère quand il accorde
plus d'importance à ses propres opinions
cause la vie d'autrui vous ai vécu
cinquante ans avec la même femme c'est
quoi votre secret elle a suivi le
premier commandement de la femme
adultère catholique tu aimeras ton
prochain comme le précédent
merci fille du pouvoir il était bien
aimable nom de rien à la politesse des
gens qui n'ont pas peur
il s'en est pas du tout pendant les
heures de boulot maintenant nous
consacrer à l'écriture vous avez moins
de pouvoirs que une époque où il n'est
pas vous avez un pouvoir énorme vous
dirigiez je suis pas combien de
d'entreprise à la fois est-ce que vous
avez pratiqué l'abus de pouvoir
non je crois peut-être si un peu on va
voir à faire une interview abus de
pouvoir
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé à être
payé pour aller sur un plateau de
télévision
oui une fois à de la rue et de la rue
beaucoup d'argent oui évidemment la
discussion c'est mal engagé parce que
j'en voulais un peu il en a beaucoup
mais ils le gardent il a bien raison
c'est comme ça qu'on devient riche mais
il me faisait venir en tant que
journaliste pour parler d'un des sujets
pas très nombreux d'ailleurs que je suis
censé connaître
c'était le jeu alors je lui ai dit
écoutez je viens mais comme je fais mon
métier que je n'ai rien à vendre
il serait normal que vous me payez alors
il a usé d'un argument imparable
et bien que je lui ai dit que je ne
viendrais pas dans son émission j'ai
admiré la dialectique il m'a dit écoutez
je ne peux pas acheter un témoignage ça
serait pas un aaa est très fort il
mérite des tristes avez vous déjà
négocié avec un animateur de ne pas
parler de votre vie privée à la
télévision non non parce que ma ma vie
privée les intéresse pas le dire dès
qu'on a vu mon physique on pense que
j'en ai pas justement en quoi les
l'erreur à m c'est l'erreur vous ai déjà
appelé un ministre pour faire sauter un
pv
écoutez j'ai dû parfois
tenté une démarche peut-être pas à la
hauteur ministériel mais un petit peu
plus bas
est ce que j'ai déjà demandé à ce qu'on
vire un journaliste qui avait écrit un
mauvais papier sera non surtout pas non
est ce que j'ai déjà voulu briser la
carrière de quelqu'un non est ce que
j'ai déjà vers une collaboratrice qui
refusait de coucher avec vous écoutez
pour qu elle refuse il aurait fallu que
je lui demanderais je m'interdis
évidemment un le droit de cuissage qui
est un usage médiévale reine aux abymes
jobs saluant des huissiers s'est rendu
beaucoup plus difficile avec la loi sur
le harcèlement sexuel qui dieu merci
n'existait pas à mes débuts
avez vous déjà demandé à être payé pour
assister une soirée non jamais mais on
me l'a pas proposé non plus cela dit il
ya des soirées où on s'ennuie tellement
que devrait justification ce serait de
revenir avec un peu plus d'argent qu'on
en avait au départ
avez vous déjà demandé qu'un membre de
votre famille sont engagés dans une de
vos émissions non je ne pèche pas par
népotisme avez vous déjà exigé une table
dans un restaurant affiché complet bah
oui moi pas beaucoup de place
on peut toujours de gazelle alors ça
mais ça m'est arrivé que l'on me fasse
une place alors que c'était complet et
vous déjà fait faire une enquête
discrète sur quelqu'un journalistique
manger parfois essayé d'en savoir
davantage mais enfin ça n'allait pas
jusqu'à engager un détective privé
oui et vous déjà exigé de savoir si vous
aviez une récompense avant d'aller dans
une cérémonie
non parce que j'en ai jamais eu ni à
l'école ni plus tard alors bon avez vous
déjà exigé de faire retoucher des photos
de vous avant parution non au nom et
vous déjà proposé un arrangement un flic
qui vient de vous arrêter l'auteur
oui ouais ouais enfin c'est de plus en
plus difficile un tout ça avez vous déjà
appelé voici pour bloquer la parution de
photos compromettantes
non parce que bon on en a jamais prises
mais si on en avait prise j'aurais
peut-être été tentée mais cela dit est
ce que on peut le faire ne pense pas
j'assume pas vous devez renier une
partie de votre passé oui sûrement
c'est toute cette partie où j'étais un
cancre où je suis j'ai poursuivi des
études sans jamais les rattraper ce qui
fait que aujourd'hui je suis obligé pour
continuer à écrire correctement à
m'entourer de dictionnaires et
d'anthologie
j'aimerais bien ne pas avoir été un
cancre j'aimerais bien avoir été
quelqu'un de brillant
j'aurais bien aimé réussir mon bac
ah oui alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
délices et qui avaient des taux de
réussite de 100 % au bac
j'habitais pas le bon quartier
[Musique]